matter
yes no you can't
oh my God you see this you're speaking
with a [__] PhD well you're doing bad
you're doing bad
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the qurani app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders Allah says in the Quran remind
for reminder benefits a Believer this
app is so phenomenal seven day free
trial wherever you are wherever you are
whatever you're doing it gives you a
reminder to read the Quran sisters we do
not need to carry the Quran in our hands
like we did before now it is on your
phone what excuse will you have on your
makayama of why you didn't read the
Quran download the qurani app now and
let it testify for you on your makayama
that you read it wherever you was enjoy
the video just ask a quick question can
you see dark matter
can you see the air now you don't see it
by exist
but you can measure it good Dark Matter
cannot be seen smelt tasted felt or hurt
no it cannot be felt
because we see the effects of it
then it can be filled no see you believe
in something that you see the effects of
but you believe you you deny God when
you see the effects of what is the
effects for example the creation you
your eye the way you created your body
your kidney your lungs your heart I'm
not creative you're not created no okay
so where did you come from it's a live
cement
bollocks of my dad where did it come
from where did it come from
where did the bollocks of your dad come
from Taiwan men away yes
and they made okay okay can you tell me
who gives the sperm the knowledge to
swim
I'm asking that's taking the question
well I'm begging you say it yeah you're
begging it okay you're available no
problem yeah exactly
how is your favorite question me asking
how does it spend half the knowledge by
saying who okay no problem that will be
a person what what gives the knowledge
what gives a knowledge to respond
intelligence where the intelligence okay
if there's intelligence then he cries
intelligent designer no okay so there's
if there's intelligence okay no problem
do you believe that there's intelligence
in this or information do you agree with
this information in this book
I read this book
any book argument said it was a
different book argument if this does
this book have information yeah okay
does that information require
intelligence
okay so are you telling me that this has
information but if there's no
intelligence behind it
information information this information
information requires intelligence
what information is I don't know the
exact definition what does it tell me no
but the information can be also anything
no of course information of course of
course yes yes so so if there's
information there's intelligence like
DNA
DNA okay does DNA have information
do you have objectives yes do you do you
believe that the DNA has information did
you hear that guys yes this person has
an objective evidence for his gut that
means a Nobel Prize is ready I'm ready
to receive
price two [__] million dollars for
you I don't need the money
okay I'm asking a simple question do you
believe that in the DNA has information
you said you had objective evidence
do you accept that DNA has information
okay
I'm just asking a simple question does
DNA have information
yeah okay good if there's information
genetic information no problem
information no problem if there's
information it requires intelligence
not necessarily okay can you tell me why
not necessarily
why not necessarily I can give you
something a phenomenon in nature tell me
snowflakes okay
yeah snowflakes have you seen a
snowflake yes on a microscope yeah
the hexagon yeah yes yes yes no
intelligence required it's just a
chemical bound oh no no no no no sorry
one second those chemical bounds have
properties to make that it's a pattern
if there is pattern then there's someone
who designed it no yes can you tell me
how you get a pattern the designer no
well you're not proven the designer
itself I am I am I'm saying those things
that you're talking about have the
innate properties to give it that shape
you're saying it came from nothingness
okay where did it come from okay where
did the properties to make the snowflake
that shape come from
physics
really what really One Second One Second
One Second One Second One Second are you
telling me blind processes gave rise to
this
for example are you telling me that the
snowflake to the DNA to the atoms which
have information all of them have
information you're telling me this
should come from physics
what do you mean by physic what does
that mean physical
no physics tells you how it works not
why it works the way it works thank you
so you're talking about how it works I'm
asking you why it works like that why is
begging the question so where brother
where did it come from I'm asked a
simple question what gave it these
intelligence information to the DNA to
the snowflake to you to the atoms there
is information where does this
information come from it requires
intelligence the honest answer we don't
know
you claim the knowledge very very simple
to me it's very simple if there is
information there has to be intelligence
and if there is intelligence of course
it does give me a contrary argument to
something that there is information but
has no intelligence
I gave you there's no no no no the
snowflake has information you're saying
it's the science of the gaps we don't
know what it is we're not going to say
it's not good so what I'm saying is
where does this information come from
did it come from nothing or somewhere
come from natural processes natural
processes are blind blind processes so
so blind no they can't no I can't
because
there is no coincidence exactly so
you're a determinist yes you can call me
whatever no no no problem if you say I
agree with you in science there is no
chances so far there is no objective
evidence for God we'll let people decide
so you believe as in science we'll let
people decide do you believe brother you
believe in science that science there is
no chance I've given you many brother
you said I said where did the
information come from the snowflake you
said physics
matter yes no you can't
you see the effects of it you are a
person who believes in science for you
you you're talking about your like more
materialistic and nuts and not in the
money sense yeah no not like that
something that you cannot see touch fill
here or taste you reject it I gave you
the example of dark matter you said we
see the effects and I say too well good
exist you don't see him but you see the
effect you see no one second you the
universe our solar system the
gravitational force all of these things
are the impact of that solar system
while that's happening do you can you
see your consciousness
because you know there is no you can't
see your Consciousness but you believe
it exists this is the hypocrite no you
cannot show me the effect
I heard the MRI fmri no they're just
scans the scans eight and nine twelve
eight and twelve you cannot you cannot
see the Consciousness we can see no you
cannot you cannot you cannot
you cannot show me okay resonance
imaging I'm gonna believe no we cannot
no it's not
that is not consciousness
we can see the thought that is not
conscious no you cannot see thoughts you
cannot see foot no you're talking about
the functions of the brain of memory
what what is responsible to think no
it's not no it's not there is a whole
discussion if the conscious is even
connected to the brain so I'm asking a
question I'm going to believe in your
Consciousness one second I'm gonna one
second bro I'm going to believe in
Consciousness if you can see it if I can
touch it if I can feel it if I can taste
it and if I can hear it
can I see you can I see Consciousness we
can see the effects of it can okay show
me consciousness
I want to see it
thank you MRI imaging is just showing
you a graph of effects the brain is
having I'm talking about Consciousness
say to me Ali here's my consciousness
you can't so then don't say it then then
you shouldn't use your argument that if
I can't see I don't believe because it
shoots you on the floor
you know why brother because you're
saying I believe in the matter what I
see but now you believe in dark matter
you can't see you believe in
Consciousness you can't see you cannot
see it
double standards this is what I say that
it's not fair brother it's not fair it's
not fair if you're going to use the
criteria the criteria should be brother
not matter because the moment you say
that you are shooting yourself on the
foot why because you believe in things
you don't see taste smell touch your
hair yeah thank you thank you but you
believe they exist electronic around you
can you see it but that's my point you
believe in things you don't see but I
tell you God exists you say no I don't
believe him you know why why because I
have the three assumptions what's
assumptions
okay can you prove it you can't exactly
I believe that I'm a dinosaur
yes and I believe I live in Pluto
yes and I fly up front and I fly on
Fridays no no I believe it's an
assumption you
see people laughing at me you know why
because it is a assumption that is
absurd
yes but we know to make the best
interested explanation to the best
influence is that we look our universe
and we see that there's intelligence if
there's intelligence there has to be an
intelligent design up that's what I'm
saying that's all I'm saying according
to your logic you're going to go now to
special bleeding because the intelligent
designer required it means intelligence
it requires also another intelligence
design no that's infinite regress the
intelligent being has to be necessary
you see special places exactly it's not
because if not if
anything has a designer except the
designer is 100 you know why because if
the God had a designer then we have the
values of infinite regress which is who
created that Designer that created a
designer
by the way it is it is no no I said it's
the phallus of infinite regress no it's
not a fallacy why is it not fallacy
mathematic is not a fallacy I'm not
talking about mathematics in mathematics
there is infinite logic in mathematics
noise abstract is logic it's I know it's
logic but in mathematics can you have
infinite yes good but in the real world
can you have infinite no no you cannot
yes okay show me a fit in the real world
[Music]
it's finite what is fighting it's finite
can you count anything is finite no no
it's finite
infinite no it's not no it's not no it's
not what is this not no it's not the
radiation if the Sun is not there is
there radiation
from the Sun we're talking about
specifically the sun we're talking about
the radiation from the sun right now
okay if the sun didn't exist now you've
given a hypothesis thank you so
therefore the sun requires to exist for
us to get radiation which shows its
dependency
you said the radiation is infinite but
it relies on the sun it is dependent I'm
not saying about the independency we're
talking about the infinite I'm talking
about dependency
I'm talking about dependencies
no I said about infinite now right
infinite doesn't exist in the real world
you know the light bulb yes neon yes
this actually has infinite radiation no
do you know what infinite is
something that has no beginning or end
no it's not necessarily
it doesn't exist in the real world okay
okay if there is okay if there's infants
between one and two you can divide those
numbers
between one and two the moment that is
limited the moment the moment the moment
you divide take away your add to
infinite it's not infinite anymore if I
have infinite amount of biryanis and I
need to be honest how many be honest we
have
you see if you understand mathematics
you know that there is no mathematics is
abstract
mathematics abstract you're talking
about a world that is abstract I'm
telling you in the real world infinite
doesn't exist and you can't prove it you
can't prove the universe no it's limited
yes it's independent as well
yes
it is rubbish no problem please that's
no problem let's go to the recycle
business here if it's rubbish one second
do you believe the universe independent
is the universe billions billions how
many how many how many
thank you that is dependency
you just gave it a number how can it be
infinite oh it's infinite thank you the
fact that you can give estimates
dependency are you really a PhD no
is 500 quadrillion the moment you give
it a number it is dependent so how would
you say no sir it's an estimation you
just disagreed with me and you said
there are 34 billion that shows its
dependency
trillion even better trillion the fact
that you can give a number shows his
dependency
so it's not infinite
but that is dependency
okay do you know what's the second law
of Thermodynamics energy cannot be
created or destroyed yeah that's the
first law first sorry first law thank
you very much first law yeah first
number diagnosis energy cannot be
created PhD you are right no no this one
you did no no no you know if you know
yes so it's first one not Second Law
okay now the point is this if energy
cannot be created or destroyed that
means that for example it doesn't mean
that it is infinite it means that it's
Eternal no it is eternal you know why
because the fact that we have a limited
amount of energy in our Universal this
dependency
I'll repeat again I repeat again energy
cannot be created or destroyed yeah for
example we as Muslims we believe in
Jannah Jannah is eternal post Eternal it
eternally relies on God for his
existence so energy is the same thing we
say energy cannot be created or
destroyed in a closed system yeah
therefore if it's in a closed system if
there's a set amount and it cannot be
created to destroyed it's dependent tell
me why I'm wrong
isolated system
okay what do you mean by isolated system
okay physics 101
this is a closed system it means it can
radiate heat to the system around it
okay and it can also get heat yes from
the system around it okay so it can get
energy yes so in this closed system yeah
and isolated system an isolated system A
system that cannot exchange energy heat
matter okay so is our universe an
isolated system yes therefore is it
dependent
within our universe universe it is
yeah really for real for real give me a
break give me a break no no no but
really really you're you're you're
always I'm just going to answer this man
I'm trying to get answers let's go back
to the verses
but you're going away from this topic
you are because
infinite doesn't exist in the world
is that infinite doesn't exist in the
real world yet my claim is that I know
energy cannot be created or destroyed in
an isolated system but the point is this
because it can for example if I set this
on fire this hasn't disappeared it's
just changed form I agree with that but
it's change form to something and and
the cycle will continue but what I'm
saying is if you go to the source which
is I believe the necessary being I
believe Allah created it gave rise to it
this system that we have it's not
infinite because we know our universe is
either dependent or independent that's
what I'm saying but
then he must be inside that system why
just so I just want to know
the name say it by itself it's an
isolated system okay why does God need
to be in the system I'm just trying to
understand please teach me because the
energy inside the system so he has to
manipulate the energy inside the system
okay he cannot be outside the system
okay so we believe Allah is
outside the creation so we say when
Allah will say Allah gives it these
properties for example we don't know if
you get a seed and put it on the floor
it drops on the floor it might turn into
a tree we say Allah gave the properties
for the earth to exist for the seed to
fool so it's automatically instantly
willed to God it all goes back to God
Almighty so we're not seeing these blind
processes so we believe energy is
created by Allah if the fact that it
cannot be created or destroyed is willed
by Allah it has those properties to do
that okay now the energy cannot be
created no no no no no no no no listen
to what I'm saying in an isolated system
yeah we're talking about when the
Universe I believe the universe is
dependent and I believe it depends on
Allah so therefore this isolated system
of the universe was willed by Allah and
the properties that happen inside which
is cannot be created or destroyed
there's an initial process of creation
from that moment onward this is what we
believe I'm seeing okay good so we
believe that Allah will dip this
isolated system now has its up
operations within it which is what the
energy within it cannot be created or
destroyed it is a function that's all
the same then it's a matter of Faith No
it's a matter of if for example the
universe is either dependent or
independent do you believe it's
dependent or independent
if you believe it's independent me and
you agree on something we agree that we
require an independent quality being
call it whatever you like you give that
title to the universe I give it to Allah
you give it energy so we will say that
your God is Universe I will why no no
but let me tell you but let me tell you
why I wouldn't worship energy no no but
let me tell you why but the fact that
you believe it's made our universe you
are in a nutshell given the attributes
that belong to Allah to Universe now at
least I have evidence okay good now I
say okay good my definition no no no no
I don't have faith a Christian they are
full faith with me I have as well logic
now independency
yeah yeah that's good together we'll
join that yeah okay so now
now if my definition of independent
being is the following it has to be
necessary self-sufficient not composed
of pieces and cannot be any other way
good okay now anything that is dependent
is something that requires something
else for his own existence is composed
of pieces and it can be any other way
now do you accept that energy is a form
of it's a peace like it's a composed of
pieces
look at the substance we agree that
energy can be any other way
you can change from good I say that is
dependent the fact that it's dependent I
say what does it depend on it has to
depend on the necessary being
that's my argument so when you said I
believe energy is the universe is
independent I'm disproving that by
seeing if it was independent it will not
be composed of pieces and it could not
be any other way we know our Universe
can be any other way and is composed of
pieces therefore it is dependent if it
if and then what is it dependent on
which is Allah that's my argument
s
physically okay okay
no no I promise you I'm not giving faith
I repeat again my definition of
dependency is the following something
that depends on something else for his
existence yeah okay guys one second
because I can't hear the brother yeah
number one if it's composed of pieces
number two if it can be any other way
the first premise premise why is it
wrong
pieces
the fact that there is a set amount
shows as dependency
set amount yes trillion for trillion
quadrillion whatever you want to call it
the fact that the energy is in an
isolated system this system is limited
even in even though the energy cannot be
created or destroyed if within the
isolated system it is still limited so
that's why I was saying sorry equals
zero what's equals zero
which means equals zero the whole total
amount
okay I don't know what that means
negative
so on the positive
okay but it has those properties so what
I'm saying is that to me something
that's composed of pieces something that
can be any other way is dependent I know
the universe is composed of pieces I
know the universe can be any other way
no no but one second that's my custom
argument if it's composed of pieces and
it can be any other way I say that thing
is dependent you said the universe is
independent I say it cannot be
independent because it is composed of
pieces you're a piece I'm a piece of the
universe therefore if I die it's not the
same universe of course the universe but
without me it's not going to be good and
it's going to be a bit boring yeah so
I'm joking yeah so my my wife might
differ with that yeah uh anyways yeah
come to my Genesis
so it cannot be it can be any other way
yeah so therefore if the universe is
composed of pieces and it can be any
other way it is not independent anymore
it is dependent what does it depend on
now that thing that it depends on has to
be independent if it's not then we have
dependency depends on dependency then we
kind of have an infinite regress that's
why we don't do the special Earth
leading we say that being has to be
self-sufficient necessary cannot be
composed of pieces and cannot be any
other way that's why it is necessary and
that's where everything stops there
outside the university it's outside
Universe it's created the universe
that's my argument
but that's still crazy no I know again
you sexually said it let me let me let
me make it clear for you it's the same
Faith as some physicists say that is
universe universe is outside our
universe it's also things thank you it's
not based on evidence yeah the same
thing that's a theory
it's a hypothesis
but yeah it's the same thing but I give
argument I think we faith I didn't say
blind I just believe I didn't say unlike
exist just believe him no no but yours
you have a Sharia
that's that's religion but I didn't come
to you with faith I came to you with a
logical argument
yes
tell me why not
no it's not it's not
but okay for example we believe gender
cannot be created is something out of
nothing that's literally no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
we believe that something can come from
nothing in what sense Allah wills it you
believe without an agent it comes from
nothing which is an impossibility okay
good so okay good if it cannot come from
nothing where did it come from
okay what's your evidence
in a
in a thank you an isolated system I'm
saying is dependent
how can I isolate very very simple very
simple this bottle that I have inside it
let's say this water is energy is open
Google and just write isolated system
can you guys open please just help him
try isolate the system yeah just like
isolated system whatever isolate system
now I'm saying imagine this is the
isolated system here in it is energy
that cannot be created or destroyed it's
just going to be here for forever
argument's sake here that is dependent
because it eternally relies on the
necessary being for its existence yes
that's my argument yes
so as you see yes click on this yeah
so you see guys yes isolate the system
cannot receive energy yes radiate energy
you cannot receive heat thank you closed
system you can exchange only heat which
other words energy yes and an open
system your your argument would work
with an open system no it works with one
of them
you know why because you said for
example
thank you please send it to my house
yeah really okay so it in an isolated
system it cannot receive or give
yeah good I have no problem with that
I'm seeing it is still limited the fact
that it cannot be created or destroyed I
accept that premise first Dynamics first
law of thermodynamics energy cannot be
created or destroyed it can change form
fully accept perfect what I'm saying is
this though you're claiming this makes
it infinite I say no okay Eternal
Eternal okay I say no because the fact
that we ask a question number one can
you prove that it is eternal in the
sense of its existence not inside the
isolated system because the fact that is
isolated and there's a specific system
shows that it is dependent that's what
I'm saying you're talking about Insight
I'm talking about the outside you're
pushing the dependency without providing
any evidence I am I'm saying inside it
cannot be created or destroyed but the
system within itself is dependent
because it cannot be Eternal it can be
infinite it cannot be
energy composed of pieces
yeah can it be any other way like less
electric yeah yeah it's dependent yeah
it's dependent
my definition of dependency is that
something composed of pieces and
something can be any other way is
dependent because the opposite of that
is the opposite no I'm not yes yes but
I'm giving my definitions composed of
pieces can be any other way those two
properties are in the closed isolated
system therefore it is requires the
independent being which is not composed
of Peace it's opposite which cannot be
any other way therefore this is my
argument
where's my phone
yes